le premier film que je recommande c'est
Elvis de base lurman Elvis raconte la
vie du caractère absolument éponyme
musicien chanteur et tout simplement
devenu mythique qui nous a quitté
malheureusement très tôt et ce que j'ai
beaucoup aimé à travers ce film c'est
non seulement la reconstitution d'époque
qui est franchement fantastique avec des
décors des costumes une interprétation
aussi de Austin Butler qui interprète le
mythe Elvis et notamment de Tom Hanks
qui m'ont beaucoup marqué et qui
vraiment retranscrivent aussi une
histoire de l'Amérique et un personnage
qui a finalement changé le monde dans
une époque où la ségrégation était
encore extrêmement marquée ce qui m'a
énormément plu aussi dans ce film c'est
l'expérience que j'ai pu vivre au
Festival de Cannes puisque Elvis y a été
présentée en première mondiale avec une
acclamation du public une véritable
ovation et beaucoup d'émotions de la
part du réalisateur et de ses acteurs